[Music]
in boos blocker news
submitted by MSG gang an Amazon driver
refused to deliver wine to a 92 year old
grandmother without ID that makes are
you [ __ ] kidding me
these guys are the these are the guys
who become like target security who are
like excuse me ma'am I take this very
seriously in shape monitors yeah home
armored guys yeah my friend was a target
security and he was the best one but the
most laziest and the most like [ __ ] up
looking the kids like super tattooed and
like never tucked in his shirt but he
always caught the criminals in the most
straight and narrow [ __ ] they were
always like power tripping and they
never caught the guys that stole [ __ ]
yeah Oh cuz the guy know what weird a
look huh yeah you just follow them on
the camera he's like okay we're watching
this group right here and it's like Ella
can't be their family and he's like yeah
they're gonna use that [ __ ] baby
carriage to put that into it he's good
that's what ended up happening yeah I
had a buddy whose target security he
called LP he's like we do loss
prevention like it cell eats like a man
so yeah so then he showed me a
highlights video that he had that they'd
pass around the company and it's him
killing people holding like LCD TVs and
I guess I'm trying to walk out the door
and [ __ ] and it's just like him like
grab him by the legs grab him from the
shoulders like used to do that you know
like physically touch them he took it so
serious it's [ __ ] hilarious I did
retail for a season for Christmas season
and so we had to get trained on loss
prevention and I really did it for the
discount and and there was like people
that like had a like you they were
pregnant or like pregnant but they it
was fake and then they would stuff it in
there but we're not allowed to like
actually touch them
and you can't even like accuse them or
make them come back in like they can
leave and look all you can do is be like
excuse me ma'am can you come back here
excuse me can you come back here
yeah they just basically appear as if
they have authority and people just come
here how is that at our deal I can walk
out but no one don't go I was at a
Target and we saw like three dudes that
were just in polo shirts and they just
came and harried this do
and a girlfriend and the girlfriend was
I the shoes gonna carry - yeah that's
funny that they're getting carried to
that one room with all the well I don't
know where it was cuz my this guy was
from the East Coast so he's showing me
the his his highlights videos from the
east I was at the Grove so you're not
touching people it was [ __ ] hilarious
though cuz he's like look at watch this
one watch this one and you're just like
you're such an that you're in the India
so this Amazon driver he had refused to
deliver liquor to this UK woman who was
92 years old maybe she looks young as
[ __ ]
she could she was 18 which is the legal
limit in the UK for alcohol well here
like you've you looked younger than 30
it's a card you they have to card you
that's true really
the yet 92 year old Mary she was Asian
and she like didn't fast trove reach
final form yet you know how they just
switch over yeah I didn't get carded
recently and I was happy I was happy and
sad you're so I was happy come like [ __ ]
yeah finally to get carded but then all
that [ __ ] does that look older you look
oldest [ __ ] dude really dude it's cuz
you're wearing a golfer hat and like you
know you have a kid so like my son and
he has as much music you can see more
collagen because then the older you get
the more like still didn't you get wait
what opposite up no know who's your baby
you end up losing it uh but like there's
like so you have baby fat only you end
up like getting older where you like get
more fat especially down here I've
noticed like it just droops
it's like starts drooping a little jig
jowls yeah and then like then you get
really old to wear it like it also then
you do a facelift
yeah and it's a hanging skin and said
when they do a facelift did they cut
your forehead and then pull it all up
yeah they do things and I just yeah I
think it really brings in I don't know I
don't know how it works but they do pull
your face up and that's like yes your
mouth usually gets bigger it's not I
like people's a class when they get
those lip fillers you look like [ __ ]
yeah what's better fool
yikes okay no one gets fillers now No
they look good I know they look natural
no wife and I'm like holy sheep and they
get like jaws and their nose gets better
I'm really chin yeah everything like
they use it like up here to pull this
stuff I'd like to get fuller in her
finger it's one of the wave batter if
you got the money I'm sure you got dude
I was leaving this honestly this meeting
downtown and this lady comes out and
with her little dog and she had the
fillers and [ __ ] and she's like she's
like how long do you think they're gonna
be here if we get in their cars and then
she takes a drink from water balls it
was not like what did she do to herself
yeah they overdid you have you been
addicted like sometimes people get
addicted in the end then what they see
in the mirror is not what people are
saying yes body this morning
mm-hmm anyway back to this Amazon driver
oh he refused to deliver liquor twice he
went this woman didn't have an ID on her
like a valid ID or whatever so then he's
like me I'm old enough hey young lady I
don't think I could deliver this here
yeah so what ended up happening is flirt
with that old [ __ ] that's all or this
this older woman her grandson sent her a
bottle of sherry her grandson who's 70
years old for new actions and so he sent
her a bottle of sherry and a jigsaw
puzzle and so the Amazon driver gave her
the jigsaw puzzle but then he needed an
ID for the alcohol and so she didn't
have it so then he took it back and then
the second time he tried to deliver it
she only had a bus pass with her photo
on it do you see my ID I don't spy
doesn't need one if she's not driving or
and she had her birth certificate but it
disintegrated probably well what if this
guy's gonna get in trouble cause like
like it won't let like there's the props
that he needs to like put it in and then
if he doesn't do that he'll get like a
strike on his record geo we're trying to
[ __ ] on this [ __ ] this guy it's the only
[ __ ] beer right thank you use your
eyes man also he goes back to maybe this
guy he he's a bit he [ __ ] up so many
times and this is his last strike I know
like if you [ __ ] miss deliver
something warm more times you've been
delivering alcohol to kids and [ __ ] he's
driven alcohol to kids with feeder make
up on their faces
I only taking any chance the ex I'm old
yeah but he's like I don't want to
[ __ ] on each other soldiers in trench
coat and a hat I thought they just left
the packages on your front door
no with alcohol they have to check your
okay I don't know about have to but they
always ask me for forgot you can get
them whenever ordered yeah I got you
sponsored by alcohol companies and I
still - oh I do - sure I do
but what if your parents aren't home and
you have to they won't leave may want to
drop it off in the minor comeback so
then yeah this whole bus pass thing they
said like it wasn't an Amazon approved
identification so he still didn't let
her have it
they don't take stone tablets either huh
yeah it's probably an Amazon rule does
this guy being like oh we're not
shooting on my name ooh oh yeah that's
right we are shooting on weight team
what do we do still shitty no we're
still [ __ ] on [ __ ] this I started
feeling bad for him right yeah [ __ ] I'm
93 she's gonna go soon bro let her look
at party it's time you come backs might
be dead yeah stupor hurt but his pose
and sharing my sober puzzle that's suck
yeah jigsaw what does jigsaw puzzle so
easy he looks young teen yeah yeah she's
cute I wanna hug her so then her
grandson said that he ended up just
getting a refund for it so he's gonna
just buy it and deliver it to her
himself you should at least get to spend
time with their grandma you [ __ ] the
country no I don't [ __ ] believe if
he's local
yeah [ __ ] this guy - boy [ __ ] maybe he's
here and he was trying to do the best he
could I was [ __ ] on him
what do you deliver that out though you
still card your grandma help your
grandma get her ID bro she looks like
she has like a butterfly collection like
she like preserved butterflies all over
her walls cute ass grandma [ __ ] love
her it's creepy to do that to
butterflies i Wilson yeah with that pins
and maybe I wouldn't deliver it races
and bar it was no no she's not races
that guitar Gary what is it about her
like she doesn't look Grace's her eyes
yeah there's these gentle eyes she's
like I don't see color yeah she has it
like she probably really live it as icy
cold good 492 my hand like this photos
20 years old yeah look at this Carlos 20
years old I got printed like I got
developed yeah I hope she still looks
like that like that what's her when she
was 60 or something just like 201 I
grandma oh oh I thought I really only
see she's got a little cute little tumor
it is like popping oh my god I don't
know I don't know your point yeah my
grandma died on her 99th birthday in
2000 Matt team
really yeah last year yeah last year her
birthday oh I think I mentioned it yeah
you did I forgot probably it was
unmemorable yeah she's not that
important to you guys so it's okay I
think I heard you saying that I was like
yeah but it's cuz it was on her birth
that is crazy
yeah she died in her sleep I can't Matt
I can't match she might wake up on her
birthday
oh yeah did she wake up on her she's
[ __ ] Alzheimer's so she wouldn't even
know it would have
like happy birthday you could have said
that on any day got it
the 1920 maybe 9 to 20 yeah Wow you
could use an ancient [ __ ] 1920 yup
my girls born 1935 Wow whoa cool story
Jesus 1930 what is that like 85 oh hey
that's all bad I'm telling them I always
ask my grandma we for years both
grandmas that are yeah so yeah but they
tell me but then I forget for some
reason I can't like keep it in my brain
way to mourn it isn't just a little
young and so you remember a younger age
probably how old is Isaac no oh damn
actually his birthday's this Sunday he's
training you know they're gonna say that
[ __ ] about us right
damn your old ass we don't understand
memes or like we didn't know something
was a meme or they call us out for our
Boomer energy yeah listen we're
Millennials listen I wear loafers I got
bloomer energy I got boomer shoes too
Wow I think I identify more as a boomer
no I don't I do you know I don't want to
be young dude I follow 18 year olds on
Twitter just so I could keep it in with
the kids to see what they're talking
about
listen do [ __ ] would I want to that yes
listen the y'all nah Dino's [ __ ]
the Young's are watching tick tock and
they like it seem upset
I'm glad I'm not one of them Young's I
don't get bring yours no I think it's
gen Z they're the cool ones right now
wait Anders cuz we're talking about the
tick-tock kids they're like even younger
than that haven't they use gen zero me
back to Gen a yeah what was happening
are we are Rebecca now I said my ABC's
Jen its Millennials ain't we next time
won't you sing with me Jen its boomers
Gen Y millennial gens e and Gen X or
something I thought it's boomers anytime
you just say something that sounds Bubo
Gen X is before Melissa it's your right
your XYZ
go to the corner then Z I'm gonna teach
Takahata say lovers so somebody can call
my boomer yeah yeah
[Music]